The relationship between the structure of these sentences, and
background knowledge is very intricate, and complex, and
very entrusting as well. Sometimes the structure of sentences can be used to
tell stories, have only implied actions in them. Consider the sentence,
John fertilized the field. Now it's hard to see fertilized mapping,
into any of the primitive actions that we had here.
There is an implied action here, that is not specified in the structure,
the sentence here. But, it is much more meaningful in terms of
the background knowledge that we have of those primitive actions. What John
fertilized the field really means, is that John put the fertilizer on the field.
Now put is something that maps in the primitive actions more easily.
The response under the feature that's processing.
Initially the inner agent must talk for the word, given in the sentence. And
try to map in the primitive actions. And if that fails, then the [INAUDIBLE]
agent must start thinking in terms of how to transform on the sentences,
to bring out implied actions, that can more easily map the independent actions.
This, again, is common sense reasoning. Through common sense reasoning,
I'm interpreting that there must be implied action here,
that captures the meaning of the sentence. Once I have made the implied action
here transparent. The the rest of the processing, easier. The put action,
maps into the primitive action of move object, this frame is pulled out, and
the rest of the slots can be filled in, like earlier.